the emergence of organic life
from what preceded it
is as dramatic a miracle as anyone could imagine.
The emergence of language from mute
bestiality, which is only 100,000 years in the past,
is as dramatic a miracle as anyone could imagine.
The emergence of a planet instantaneously
unified by electricity and media is
- and this is only 50, 60 years in our past, it's still going on -
is as dramatic a miracle as anyone could imagine.
It's absolutely irrational
to not be filled with the fire of consuming hope.
You just have to overcome
the leveling that we inherit
from these empty, existential scientific ideas.
And when we do that
and lift our eyes to the real, living
spiritually
empowered reality that exists in nature,
in society, in our lover
in ourselves,
then you see that the peacock's tail, the cauda pavonis,
is a transcendental object at the end of time.
An enormous.. uhh..
unspeakable something..  that beckons
across the historical landscape, that casts an enormous shadow
that reaches clear back to the earliest moments of the universe.
That we have always been in the grip
of that iridescent, strange attractor.
It has propelled our poetry, our art.
Our best moments have always been
when the tiny spark of that alchemical completion
burned for a moment in our mind,
in our life, in our perception.
And we occupy a special position
in regard to this. Millions..
thousands of generations
of human beings, have come and gone and could only
glimpse this in the ecstasy
of eroticism and psychedelic empowerment
and ritual magic.
But we are...
.. the last people.
Beyond us lies the mystery,
if we have but the courage to move forward into that abyss.
To believe that nature will reward
the dreamer. It cannot wander
much longer. All of the preconditions
have been met and the peacock's tail
grows daily, whiter, and more
radiant and more brilliant, as we
sense now, breaking into our dreams,
breaking into our waking lives, the presence
of this attractor.  It has always given people meaning
but we are the privileged inheritors
of that meaning. And we have then,
the privilege of putting it all together
in one piece and standing ready at the end of
history, to go into
the mystery and be completed.